7,000 NHS staff have now been tested and
next alongside testing
we're intensively researching drugs and
treatments right since the start of this
crisis we've been clear that all our
plans are based on the best possible
science and that science gets better
every day but there's still a lot that
we don't know about how to treat and
potentially prevent kovat 19 so research
about treatments is absolutely central
to our plan
the UK of course has a long tradition
that we're very proud of of being the
best in the world in this sort of
science and we are a world leader in
clinical trials and we're putting this
to use right now bringing together some
of the finest research minds in the
country to design new trials and we're
delivering them at record pace as well
we've established three national
clinical trials covering each major
stage of the disease primary care
hospital care and critical critical care
for the most seriously ill and just like
the nightingale one of these trials was
in fact put together in just nine days
which is breathtaking speed these trials
are looking at the effects of existing
drugs and steroids repurposed for
treatment of kovat 19 one of the trials
which is called recovery which deals in
hospital care is the largest of its kind
in the world with 926 patients enrolled